[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein rezept was sich schon
viele von mir gewünscht haben
die letzten plätze ist ein also ich
kenne aus der türkei ein türkisches er
aber das gibt es auch in vielen anderen
kulturen also ich will da nichts
falsches behaupten und zuletzt gibt es
auch aus dem spanischen seelisch also
drei mädels und dieses der wird auch
typischerweise aus drei milchsorten
gemacht nämlich kugel schafsmilch und
ziegenmilch wir haben hier jetzt nur
eine kuh mit die meisten machen das auch
nur noch so weil man es einfach nicht
mehr bekommt war auf dem land also bei
mein papa früher im dorf da hat man
wirklich noch drei q3 milchsorten
benutzt da gab es ist auch noch aber bei
uns hier ist es eigentlich ja also wir
finden sie nicht hier
von daher mache ich jetzt mit einer
milchsorte so wie es momentan in der
türkei zubereitet wird das dessert ist
ein mensch der wie gesagt und es ist
auch wirklich super leicht also wenn man
es ist schmeckt nicht so süß trotz einer
leckeren karamell schicht und die basis
des desserts ist ein schöner lockerer
kuchen und dafür brauche ich auch nur
wenige zutaten 6 eier die sind bereits
zimmer waren 250 gramm zucker eine prise
salz und etwas vanille extrakt 150 gramm
mineralwasser 150 gramm sonnenblumenöl
420 gramm mehl und dreieinhalb teelöffel
backpulver in kolumbien mexiko und
venezuela wird übrigens dass es sehr
fast so ähnlich gemacht nur ohne diese
karamell schicht habe ich gesehen und
dem türkischen witz eben mit karamell
schicht gemacht und die macht auch
wirklich super besonders also die eier
kommen jetzt in die rührschüssel wie
gesagt zimmer war so lassen sie sich
besser und voluminöser aufschlagen dann
etwas salz und zucker
ihr könnt hier auch gerne den zucker
reduzieren meine rezept variante ist
auch schon zucker reduziert
normalerweise ist noch süßer aber dann
ist es uns einfach zu heftig etwas von
neil extrakt und jetzt könnt ihr die
zutaten für etwa 15 minuten richtig
schön cremig und also soweit die cremig
aufschlagen
wieso bist fit
denke ich
bisschen
lecker lecker lecker nicht wegschmeißen
weil ja
perfekt sei die massiv aus da kommen
jetzt die beiden flüssigkeiten dazu also
wasser und sonnenblumenöl ganz kurz ein
rührender niedriger stufe und ich habe
hier schon mal mehl und backpulver
vermischt gibt die zutaten jetzt in ein
sieb damit sie nicht lumpen
jetzt bei niedriger stufe ganz kurz
einrühren
[Musik]
viele packen cilic in einer glasform
weil er später die milch dazu kommt und
der kuchen getränkt wird jetzt aber auch
hier schon in meinem eckigen back rahmen
probiert ist wirklich super und der
vorteil ist ihr bekommt das dass er
später eben auch wieder schön raus ich
kann den rahmen später nämlich einfach
entfernen und aus der glasform svi mit
tiramisu bekommt man es einfach das
erste stück zumindest nicht so schön
raus ich habe ich jetzt auch große
einstellung eingestellt ich habe jetzt
auch eine back folie drunter und hier
kommt jetzt der lockere luftige tag
hinein
[Musik]
dann kann der kuchen jetzt schon den
backofen und ich kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die karamellsoße
zu bereiten die muss nämlich abkühlen
und stadt kann ich die zeit schön nutzen
[Musik]
dafür braucht er auch nur diese drei
zutaten nämlich 170 gramm zucker 25
gramm butter und 250 km h
die sahne ist jetzt auch nicht mehr
kühlschrank kalt dem zucker gebe ich
jetzt einfach in einen kleinen topf
stellen den herd auch mittel hohe hitze
und lass ihn einfach karamellisieren
jetzt ja auch am anfang gar nicht spüren
sondern wirklich nur den zucker vor sich
hin köcheln lassen natürlich aufpassen
dass er nicht verbrennt daher auch nur
mittel hoher hitze und dann kann ich
jetzt gleich schon mal die anderen
zutaten richtung das sind es dauert
jetzt ein paar minuten
[Musik]
jetzt sieht man hier schon ganz gut wie
sich der zucker auflösung karamellisiert
da wirklich gut aufpassen aber noch
nicht rühren noch ein bisschen vor sich
hin karamellisieren lassen und ruhig
hier ganz vorsichtig durch der zucker
löst sich jetzt gerade noch
karamellisiert aber auch schon also
wirklich vorsichtig sein und die farbe
die darf dann schon so ein bisschen
braun werden also ein etwas dunkleres
brown aber nicht zu dunkel
ansonsten wird die karamellsoße nämlich
bitter muss einfach wieder schön klar
und durchsichtig werden stumme ich
nominiere ich dieses rezept nachzumachen
was du aber nicht benutzen darf ist die
turbo taste auf deinem kopf fällt denn
sonst karamellisiertem zucker nicht er
verbrennt direkt das bin ich mal
gespannt
jetzt komme ich so langsam an die
richtige farbe ran also so sieht das
karamell momentan aussieht schon
ziemlich fertig aus aber ein bisschen
karamellisierte durchsichtiger wird er
gleich noch so sieht super aus guck mal
so muss die farbe sein
und seid da wirklich nicht ungeduldig
und macht wirklich nur auf mittel hoher
stufe ansonsten verbrennt wirklich super
schnell entweder zieht das jetzt vom
herd kurz runter oder schaltet den herd
ganz kurz etwas hinunter da kommt jetzt
die butter rein da merkt man da noch
immer wie heiß karamell wirklich ist und
jetzt die sahne dazu und da passiert
jetzt gleich dass das karamell festwirt
ist aber nicht schlimm denn wir lassen
es gleich sowieso aufkochen zitiert
lakatos wir sind ungeheuer aber das löst
sich jetzt hier gleich wieder in der
heißen sonne auf
[Musik]
ja selbst den herd einfach wieder hoch
stellen auf mittel hohe hitze und schön
aufkochen lassen
so ist die konsistenz jetzt gerade das
ist sehr flüssig aber trotzdem fließt so
an einem faden herunter und wenn ich vom
löffel runter tropfen lasse ich lasse
jetzt noch kurz eine halbe minute kochen
und dann ist die soße fertig also die
muss wirklich schön flüssig bleiben
nicht so fest damit ich sie später eben
auch schon drüber gießen kann zum
ausprobieren können die sie aber
trotzdem immer gerne einfach so einen
löffel voll in ein schälchen geben und
auskühlen lassen
ich schaue jetzt auf dem herd aus und
wenn ich gleich merke dass die
karamellsoße hier doch noch zu flüssig
bleibt kann ich sehr noch mal eine
minute kochen lassen ansonsten ist er
wirklich perfekt und die muss jetzt
einfach komplett auskühlen
solange die karamellsoße abkühlt kann
ich schon mal die milch machen also die
zum tränken
dafür habe ich hier einen liter milch
200 gramm sahne und 100 gramm zucker und
damit sich dazu jetzt hier auch schon
auflöst gebe ich die sahne in ein
kleines schälchen es muss nicht gekocht
werden einfach nur erwärmt werden so
dass der zucker sich auflösen kann
reicht also wirklich wenn es nur etwas
lauwarm wird
und wenn es dann nicht mehr so kratzt am
boden dann weiß ich dass der zucker
aufgelöst ist
dann gebe ich die sahne zucker mischung
einfach zur milch dazu las es abkühlen
und das muss dann auch wirklich schön
kalt sein wenn der kuchen dann heiß aus
dem ofen kommt der zucker hat sich jetzt
schon aufgelöst
da kann ich einfach hier zur milch
dazugeben und wie gesagt diese mischung
einfach schön abkühlen lassen und jetzt
noch die dritte komponente bzw die
vierte herstellen den kuchen haben wir
schon die karamellsoße habe ich die
milch und jetzt kommt noch die auf
geschlagene sahne und dafür brauche ich
jetzt einfach nur 600 gramm kalte
schlagsahne etwas vanille extrakt um
seiner partner path habe ich hier immer
schön abgefüllt und nehmen den teelöffel
und die sahne kann ich jetzt einfach
hier mit vanillecreme
kann ich jetzt hier die sahne schlagen
und seiner partner umgeben und steif
schlagen
aber bevor die sache komplett steif ist
muss ich gleich dass etwas rausnehmen
für die deko
[Musik]
jetzt ist die krise noch nicht ganz
steif ich brauche ein bisschen was für
die deko ich habe jetzt hier einfach von
der gefriert hüte die könnt ihr über ein
glas stülpen
unser ungefähr 50 gramm sind so drei
esslöffel könnt ihr hier einfach rein
geben und die restliche creme schön
schreib schlagen und dann einfach im
kühlschrank stellen
der kuchen ist jetzt nämlich auch gleich
fertig
[Musik]
perfekt dies jetzt auch schön steil
die kriegen kann auch zur seite der
kuchen gebacken ich habe ihn auch zehn
minuten abkühlen lassen aber er ist noch
schön warm und jetzt nehme ich einfach
ein zahnstocher und steche hier kleine
löcher rein so kann die milch nämlich
gleich besser hinein sinken
und hier kommt jetzt die milch mischung
darüber wie gesagt ist jetzt wieder
schön kalt der kuchen ist war einfach
ganz vorsichtig tränken
[Musik]
und das hier wirklich nach mega event
aus aber wie gesagt das ist so nah
saftiger mit kuchen und den kuchen lasse
ich jetzt einfach abkühlen
ich stelle ihn dann danach sogar noch in
den kühlschrank damit er schön kalt wird
und viele nehmen jetzt dafür zum backen
deswegen eine glasform weil sie denken
dass einfach die milch eben auslaufen
könnte wie gesagt könnt ihr auch gerne
glasform nehmen wenn ihr eine kleinere
menge zubereiten wollte könnte es auch
gerne umrechnen oder wenn ihr glasform
habt in meiner app könnt ihr nämlich
einfach eure maße angeben und dann
rechnet die app ganz automatisch die
zutaten runter also ich kann jetzt im
prinzip nur noch machen alles abkühlen
lassen und dann geht es gleich weiter
perfekt läuft nichts ausweg perfekt
jetzt alles schön kalt und ich kann mein
ziel m einen schönen blechkuchen einfach
fertig stellen so das ganze hab ich
jetzt noch hier
ich habe ich meine sahne die streiche
ich jetzt zuerst mal auf den kuchen
schöne dünne schicht einfach verteilen
[Musik]
die fläche ist schön glatt
jetzt kommt die kalte karamellsoße
drüber
[Musik]
die jetzt mit einer sauberen palette
verstreichen und darauf achten dass sich
die zwei schichten jetzt auch nicht
vermischen
die karamellsoße so schön drauf legen
jetzt kommt noch der letzte schritt
nämlich die zurückgelegte creme und wie
schneide ich jetzt ganz kleine spitze
weg zu einem mini öffnung ein bisschen
größer und damit ziehe ich jetzt hier
einfach streifen ein aber ich mache das
jetzt hier längst
und vom abstand her so etwa zwei bis
drei zentimeter
[Musik]
was jetzt noch nicht so ganz schön
aussieht macht ihr jetzt mit einem
zahnstocher den abstieg spielt ich habe
jetzt einfach so ein metallstück spies
und damit zieht es einmal von oben nach
unten und dann von unten nach oben so
schöne muster rein okay und dann wird es
wirklich richtig schön und das würde ich
schon sagen kann jeder
[Musik]
und ich mache das eigentlich auch nicht
nur rein oberflächlich sondern gehe
wirklich so ein halben zentimeter tief
rein
so habt ihr wirklich richtig schöne
struktur und fertig und es sieht aus als
hätte es jemand professionelles gemacht
schon cholera bis gerade eben habe ich
noch gedacht was macht sie da oder und
so denke ich jetzt meint roger applus es
schön durch kühlen am besten täglich
vier bis fünf stunden oder über nacht
und dann können wir probieren und ihr
seht es wirklich jetzt eine riesengroße
menge also wenn ihr wirklich besuch
bekommt an ramadan zum fastenbrechen man
könnte dieses dessert zubereiten es hält
sich auch zwei bis drei tage im
kühlschrank schön verpackt natürlich und
wenn ihr sagt ihr wollt eine kleinere
menge rechnet wie gesagt einfach im blog
unter er herunter ich stellte jetzt kurz
karls und wenn es kalt ist können wir
probieren
[Musik]
das dessert ist jetzt richtig schön kalt
ich ziehe jetzt hier einmal vom blech
runter zweiter fall hier ein schafft
zwar krass okay der türkei sehr sehr
bekanntes rezept beide namen heißt er
drei milch oder ja und ja und es kommt
aus dem italienischen es kann sein dass
die spanisch ehrlich es kann sein dass
wir gleich in jedem land ein bisschen
anders macht oder männer haben das auch
was ich kenne das aus spanien kolumbien
venezuela ehrlich ja ich weiß nicht ob
ich jetzt sieht dass das bestimmt 20
nein es kommt für uns einiges oregano es
herkommt der schmeckt einfach richtig
toll
in der türkei ist richtig bekannt und
jetzt bundes oder die türken sagen jetzt
doch kolossal sonne meer ja krass große
menge wie gesagt es ist ein paar tage
haltbar 23 trage eben aufgrund der sahne
und jetzt nicht bis er auf der dauer
back folie schneiden mit einem scharfen
messer aber ihr könnt auch wirklich ein
stumpfes messer nehmen so wird sich das
marzipan messer denn es ist schön weich
das marzipan weise heißt man kann damit
auch von dann schneiden nur entscheidend
auf hunde und eigentlich schneide ich
meistens von dort damit fast niemand
zuhören
ich müsste erstmal umgangen und was ist
wenn man kein song besser und da kann
man auch den rücken eines normalen
messenger oder seine palette an die
panik am oder sohn noch mathematik um
das ist mir auch sehen dass in der
palette auch geht sauberer fahren
jährlich okay wenn man sie dann macht es
wieder palette und so ideal zum kaffee
richtig cool oder auch zum thema sowieso
und herrchen
wir sind doch schon langsam frei war das
ist keiner mehr ab her auch mit da okay
jetzt kommen wie schön es ausgeht
gerade einfach noch von einem teller ist
es cool ist kulisch du hast den teig ich
milch trinke ja der kopf ist mit drei
wochen passau
und er ist nicht schwer das hat jetzt
der schmeckt total leicht obwohl schon
gemacht
ich muss doch etwas machen war ich bin
realistisch aber ich meine ich habe auch
schon ordentlich salacher programm erst
jetzt schmeckt nicht so süß ich habe
auch einmal gedacht durch die karamell
schicht das ist ein süßer corinne ist
aber gar nicht im sommer totaler quatsch
und jetzt ist das schwierige an den
kugelschreiber mail oder so wird es auch
einfach das war auch einfach alles
einfach wenn man das rezept beachtet
also macht es gut machen ist präsent
probiert gerne mal auf ich schreibe euch
natürlich das rezept auf meinem blog mix
sagt können das auch unter rechnen ganz
einfach wände app also wir essen jetzt
davon locker mit dem gesamten themen
schon so 23 tag als ihr können auch gern
weniger zu bereichern coole kraut viele
glaube ich ist ein mega kraut viel und
vor allem zum ramazan bayrami zu
erweitern kann man super mein name ist
dass man unser ist er komme immer gäste
fast die ganze völkerwanderung dann
denken wir mal her was ich jetzt
passiert aber bei uns auf jeden fall so
popp jetzt aus postet eure bilder und
verlinkt mich darauf dann sehe ich es
und dann kommentieren wir es auch und
like uns auch noch bis zum nächsten mal
gysi voll lecker ich bin eigentlich kein
karamell fan aber ich bin absolut firma
der kugeln ist der oberhammer wirklich
noch 1 die anderen auch in anholt dass
ich einfach nochmal ein stück
als mein papa ich muss noch mal
probieren
also ultras ist falls oft
auch er kann der körper mit soße und
kann
du kannst es vorher auch nicht aber es
geht einfach runter also kann man apple
ja wenn es machen wenn es nach mir ginge
könnte man sogar noch einen drauf machen
es lieb sein also sonne und milch
schnitte machen
ich glaube da bleibt auch lange weich
und saftig wieder ist vor allem hält er
nicht mehr so genau muss ausprobieren
[Musik]